[Music]
we organized his extraordinary Eurogroup
meeting today to advance on our agenda
to strengthen the euro with a view to
deliver a good reform package to our
leaders in the December summit we focus
on three main building blocks banking
union ESM reform and the instruments for
competitiveness convergence and
stabilization banks are more resilient
and there is significant progress with
the legislative processes for several
risk reduction measures at EU and
national level lastly we have a very
good discussion on a new fiscal
instrument for the euro area the French
and German finance ministers presented
their recent proposal on the
architecture of a rural area budget
ministers welcomed this contribution new
zphone sheep Bali disruption poof
another liquidity the Balkan Cordova's
will show the proceed on TCP not shown
you backstop ivana funded by the
connection applicable from Universal
shown the million CAD DM Jade Palace
Allah a funding mechanism a hope a no
stability no discussion Oda booty in
position coming soon our operation
future on context all a coup ms let me
start with the agreement that the ESM
and Commission reached on our future
cooperation I'm very happy with that
agreement because I think we found a
good balance that can draw on each
other's comparative advantage
[Music]